okay thank you so I'm working opera I
work as a lead developer at Bbox
which is a company serving developing
markets serving the roughly 1 billion
people who don't have access to
electrical grid we want to provide them
with clean affordable and sustainable
energy sources and other utilities and
as interesting as that sounds this is
actually a sort of private project that
was done after hours and it's very
loosely related to be box so a big box
we have this pool table and like can
your pool table do this I hope not
because you know you'll be excused to
say that it's just slanted into to one
side it's not it's slanted in all
different sides and it's kind of
unpredictably started that way so what
do you do obviously you you want to
write some code to actually tell you how
how uneven the table is and there's some
real-life motivation there it's an
unpredictable system and we have a pool
tournament so there is pressing needs to
assess the fairness of of the tournament
because you know if it's if for someone
it the balls just going into pockets on
their own it's not it's not fair and so
the constraint I had was just that there
should be no extra set up which makes it
considerably harder so if you if you
look at sort of professional pool
tournaments they would have a camera
mounted on top of the table and you
could see everything clearly here I was
just taking a video of the pool table
from the sides and I asked other people
to submit their videos as well so it
would just be from a range of different
mobile phones you know
like that and a disclaimer I'm really
bad at pool so some people apparently
can spin the cue ball intentionally and
argue that so yep I made the assumption
that the ball should just collide and
then go into a straight line which is a
very negative assumption so bear that in
mind so why did is I split this into a
few into a few tasks that are sort of
more or less easy to do all of them so
first of all I detected where the table
was and where the initial positions of
the balls were and then used OpenCV to
attract those then transform that into a
reference frame so from trapezoids into
a two by one rectangle then sex the
collision split the sequence into
different different tracks that the
balls were going try to quantify how
much skew from a straight line that was
and correlated that with some of the
results from our tournament and there's
bonus visualization at the end as well
so yeah the first thing and OpenCV is
actually pretty great at object tracking
from a video if you know that is where
the objects are to begin with so this is
an example of overall set shot where you
know if you have the region of interest
if you know where the balls already are
then the accuracy is pretty good it you
know it has some problems with say one
one ball hitting the other so this
there's some stuff that you might need
to work out but it's it's pretty great
so detecting objects on the other hand
is a bit more of a challenge but there
is this good heuristic that you have
this big blue thing in the middle which
is a pool table why not use that so what
it was exactly that so I the first step
was to find where the pool table is find
the corners and then limit the search
space for the blobs to just that that
piece of the image a little note on
color spaces we're used to red green
blue representation in in images but
what is actually very useful in this
case is representing this setting in hue
lightness saturation space where things
that are blue would be closer together
to to each other on one dimension and
they would differ on the other two and
the advantage of that is that yeah when
you take a little patch of the table say
take the average of that then filter
filter the part of the image that are
within a certain range of of this value
it works much better on
hls space than on red marine blue space
an extra bonus is that it also applies
to images taken from a different camera
or images taken at a different time of
day when it's you know slightly darker I
do not like do anything with the color
collection that was done by the camera
itself that might be another thing to do
if you want to I don't have that as an
embedded application or something like
that so the first step after you you
threshold it on the table area is to
apply edge detection and again OpenCV is
great with that it has a canny edge
detection after the box it works pretty
well and then you can apply opening and
closing so opening would be sort of
eroding the the little edges first so if
things are small it would get rid of
them and then it would expand so it
would
yeah it would basically close all the
edges and you're closing it does does
the opposite thing it it it first
expands it inroads so it makes the
shapes sort of fuller and another
heuristic approach here you just take
the biggest contour of these and take
that as the table after that you just
take convex hole which is the the
biggest of polygon that encompasses the
whole the whole contour and these are
all OpenCV functions so they're you know
easy to use and okay once I did that I
use simple blob detection blob is a
technical term I here to get the initial
positions of the of those bowls and now
there's another heuristic that you need
to find the cue ball which is again like
the void ball so you can you can use the
same approach as for finding the table
it's the one that has a color that's
similar to this this particular one and
his his a visualization I think I think
the polygon might not be actually
updating phone but you see and the four
corners of the table so that is that
it's something that I took from this so
yeah you have this you have this polygon
and it is actually composed of a few
lines on top and on the sides and so you
can apply something like k-means to
cluster the line equations into four
clusters and take the centroids of those
four clusters as the equations for the
sides of of the well trapezoid and so
after that you can just find
intersections of these lines that's
relatively simple algebra
and take the intersections are actually
within the picture because you know the
lines would go off and finally intersect
somewhere else as you saw in the
previous video if you just take the if
you just take the raw positions of the
corners they kind of jump around based
on what the what you detect in a certain
frame you can just smooth them over time
to avoid this jitter and make it sort of
relatively uniform okay
so now you have you have the position of
the bolt in this trapezoid space you
have there the corners of this trapezoid
and you can just use a function from
OpenCV again to get it like transform
positions from this one space into
another and the next step would be to
detect the ball collisions and I use the
Raymer Douglass poker I think algorithm
which finds the sharp turns in a
sequence of positions is what OpenCV
uses for simplifying shapes of objects
as well so basically it it takes a very
sort of nosey positioned noisy vector of
positions and finds the points in in
which there's a sharp turn and I did
that because where the bowls are
actually most acceptable to skewing into
one direction is when they're at the
last bit when they're when they're at is
lowest and so now we can go to the the
actual part that was interesting it's
begin with which is quantifying how much
the tables skewed and again the
assumption here is that balls are going
in straight lines so you can try to fit
a straight line to say the first half of
the XY coordinates
and you just use that using an umpire so
I thought function to it if it
that's this of one degree polynomial so
a straight line and then you can
calculate the mean standard error or
some other and some other measure of
variation from from this straight line
so you actually need to rotate that so
that the straight line goes in the
survey x-axis direction and then you can
calculate mean standard error and now
correlating it with the pool table pool
table tournament results which was
actually the hardest part because I'm
not sure if you ever tried to get people
to do something voluntarily without any
explicit award it's hard there was a
really low participation rate but for
those videos that mostly I took and from
the fee that I got from other people it
turns out that there's about 10% higher
skew for game winners than game losers
and the weak negative correlation
between tournament positions so the
lower the number so the higher the
position the hardest queue it was no
significant because well it was pretty
noisy data does that mean that if the
table is more skewed you're more likely
to win possibly but I think skill in
this case was still a better predictor
some people as I said just spoke the
ball by I don't know magic I think and
so it did actually go straight on
purpose and maybe some people actually
use what they know about the table to do
those charts so the shot I showed at the
beginning
yeah like some people would do that on
purpose
so now there's some bonus utilization so
this is the kind of end to end the end
to end video so you can see the the pole
position I don't have the transformed
mapping but yeah that would be that
would be so another step and also this
represents the sort of average of of
shots so right here is as I said in
order to calculate the deviation from
straight line you will need to rotate
the rotate the shot and calculate the
deviation like that I also normalize the
lengths to be standard lengths so you
can see you can compare two shots one by
one like so and you can see a good sort
of straight edge line shot and a pretty
bad badly skewed one in red okay so in
terms of next steps was linear
assumption there a better one might be
you know trying to get some normalized
norm data from a level table that might
be one thing to do in order to not use
this linear assumption and the blob
detection actually could do it better so
there might be you know something like
if you don't have a clue gene it works
great but if you do it's a bit harder
and yeah not sure if what what's what's
the best way to do that it'll be good to
get more data samples and somehow tag
them as well so if we had ground true
for some of them we could do something
that's more supervised okay thank you
very much
[Applause]
give any questions yep so you showed us
the visualization and my question is
about the speed of your algorithms would
you be able to run it in real time or it
was just prepared and it runs on my
laptop in probably about three times the
length of the video which means if you
had something with a GPU you could
probably do it in real time
more or less OpenCV is pretty it's
pretty good at using GPUs is written in
C++ the pipe in finding that was using
you might it might be faster in C++ hmm
thank you very much for your talk I want
to ask did you count as a distortion of
the camera
no so again as I said if you had an
embedded system you could actually get
the accelerometer and I mean for example
GoPro cameras get you could get you
could get very fishy eye image okay yeah
so not straight yet so I did take the
four corners but I didn't then account
for like how bendy the lines were but it
[ __ ] correct with that I think couldn't
make I mean could it enhance its
predictions possibly yeah if the balls
were if you if you knew that the shapes
were a necessarily circular that would
probably help with blob detection yeah
thank you
Thanks
thanks for the talk just a quick
question in terms of further stuff that
you could do did you think of mapping
the kind of issues with the table which
spots on the table and your D projects
that seemed to be deflecting the
trajectories of the balls and direction
yeah that's that's a good point I could
do something like a heat map of where
the balls are actually leaning towards
and it would probably be a sort of
spherical almost surface in other
questions okay so thank you very much
[Applause]